let's take a look at some of the weapons
that the west has sent to ukraine as
well as those that are expected soon i'm
joined by air marshal edward stringer a
former director of operations at the
ministry of defence um and then just
take us through some of the weapons that
the west has already given or pledged to
give to ukraine oh good afternoon jane
well
no weapon is purely offensive or
defensive but very clearly early on the
west was making sure the weapons it gave
were very much at the defensive end of
the spectrum so you have the top here
anti-tank missiles the n law and the
javelin and here the star streak
anti-aircraft anti-aircraft missile only
really useful if someone drives a tank
or an aircraft into your country and at
you and pledged down here we have the um
saber which is the uh drone which the
americans have now pledged but only
about a hundred um and this is
essentially in the bigger version just a
javelin warhead with a drone that can
take it a little bit further than a
javelin can reach on the battlefield so
a little bit more offensive but still
very much at the defensive end of the
spectrum so these are all things that
could be used against russian military
but there wouldn't be much use to a
country if it wanted to evade in other
countries so therefore russia could say
ukraine could argue that these are
purely purely
defensive yes and the west can say we
are helping ukraine to defend itself
against aggression we are not allowing
it to take or sponsoring it to take the
fight to russia or in russia
then the next step of course is slightly
more offensive uh and let's look at some
of the things that again the west has
promised or or is sending or has sent so
far
yes and what you've got here at the top
are weapons that ukraine already has and
that's important because these weapons
need to be kept serviceable and that
means spares they need to be maintained
and your troops need to know how to use
them and get the best out of them so
the czechs are talking about providing
the t-72 tank and the bmp-1 infantry
fighting vehicle
and that will be of great help
to ukraine
down here the uk has pledged slightly
less offensively but nevertheless still
very useful protective mobility and you
have the mastiff and the jackal
which will allow them to get troops
around the battlefield with a slightly
uh enhanced uh element of protection and
you've made the point that it's not much
use of sending one or two of each it's
much more useful to the ukrainians if
they're sent a lot of one thing so they
can focus their uh knowledge on it and
that they have the spares and things for
it yes absolutely and that's why sending
them stuff that they've already got and
you win wars by
simplifying prioritizing and then doing
it at scale and the west has to come
together to work out how it's going to
keep providing this to ukraine so it
doesn't run out of war winning weapons
before russia does and finally jets
ukraine has said that they do want
planes they want help poland potentially
sending these kind of jets uh is that a
step too far is that then moving on to
the the offensive line well that's been
a political calculation to date we we
mentioned that spectrum of offensive to
defensive and even though the mig-29 is
very much an a defensive air defense
fighter it's still got a long range it
could um
penetrate into into russian airspace so
the calculation so far has been that
this would be a step too far even though
the ukrainian air force has been asking
for it for many weeks but i think what
we're seeing with some of those tanks an
infantry fighting vehicles is that
political calculation is beginning to
change and we're moving up that spectrum
from defensive to a bit more offensive
okay martial edward stringer thanks very
much
thank you